[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei Bild made in
Germany ja das ist bei mir zu Hause noch
der Staubsauger die Waschmaschine und
das war mal das ultimative
Qualitätsversprechen unser
Wirtschaftswunder die Garantie für
unseren Wohlstand diese Garantie ist weg
die Industrialisierung das ist das
deutsche angstwort made in Germany war
es das diskutiere jetzt mit diesen
Gästen mit Erik Marquardt im Grünen
Europa Parlamentarier mit Fritz
fahrenhold Energiemanager und früher
umweltssenator für die SPD in Hamburg
Helmut Markwort ist bei uns der Gründer
des Fokus und
FDP-Abgeordneter heute im Bayerischen
Landtag Jana Schimke ist bei uns
CDU-Bundestagsabgeordnete und Oliver
helldörfer er hat ein Metzgereibetrieb
ein Traditionsunternehmen in Bamberg und
muss das jetzt auch wegen der hohen
Energiepreise aufgeben in diesem Jahr
ihnen allen herzlich willkommen bei Bild
Herr Marquardt besitzen sie irgendwas
made in Germany worauf sie richtig stolz
sind dass es made in Germany ist
ehrlicher nicht nein
es ist nichts Auto Waschmaschine
Kühlschrank Staubsauger und und und
nichts ja also ich habe ein Auto das
muss ich sagen dass es made in Germany
ich weiß nicht ob ich darauf richtig
stolz bin aber es fährt mich von A nach
B Herr Marquardt ist genau das das
Problem dass wir es verlernt haben zu
schätzen was made in Germany ist das
wirklich unseren Industriestandort zu
pflegen zu schätzen stolz zu sein also
ich bin da eher der altmodische Typ ich
achte auf deutsche Produkte haben
deutsches Auto und deutschen Kühlschrank
viele Deutsche Gegenstände aller Art und
damit leiste ich meinen kleinen Beitrag
zur
industriebewegungen in Deutschland sie
sind aus einer anderen Generation das
darf ich ja sagen sie sind 36 geboren
Menschen sie sind aufgewachsen im
wirtschaftsmunder sie waren dann gerade
erwachsen als Deutschland zu Blüte kam
was bedeutet für sie made in Germany ja
ich habe ihn sogar noch im
Luftschutzkeller groß geworden ja ganz
schrecklich habe den Produkte Amis noch
erlebt ja
habe einen gesunden Patriotismus der mit
Nationalismus nichts zu tun hat ein
Patriot ist ja mal der stolz ist auf
sein Land ohne die anderen Länder
feindselig anzusehen und deswegen habe
ich immer darauf geachtet dass deutsche
Dinge bei mir im Haushalt sind geht das
gerade den Bach runter made in Germany
ich habe mir die größte Sorge die
Energiepreise treiben die Industrie raus
aus Deutschland wir haben die
allerhöchsten in
Energiepreise in ganz Europa ich habe es
mir sogar aufgeschrieben wir zahlen 31,8
Euro für ein Kilowatt ja die Franzosen
18 die Engländer 24 USA 12 also das ist
dermaßen teuer und mehr als die Hälfte
davon sind aber Steuern und Abgaben also
da könnte man was machen aber mit denen
mit den Energiepreisen kann sich keine
Industrie in Deutschland halten die
höchsten Energiepreise der Welt hat
sofort Fritz fahren Umfeld hier ergänzte
er Markwort also Fritz fahrenhold der
langjährige Energiemanager der jeden
Preis parat hat aktuell auch sie kommen
aus dieser aus einer ähnlichen
Generation zumindest auch für sie ein
bisschen jünger bin aber auch sie haben
das Wirtschaftswunder erlebt das
bedeutet für sie made in Germany ja mit
den Germany war Qualität war
besondere
Güte der Produkte und was wir auch nicht
vergessen dürfen besonders effizient
hergestellt
deswegen kämpfe ich so für jeden
Arbeitsplatz in Deutschland weil es wird
ja verkannt wenn ein Arbeitsplatz hier
vernichtet wird sei es wenn Mercedes
seinem Motoren in China produzieren
lässt dann steigt die Emissionen um das
Fünffache weil dieses Deutschland hat
eben auch schon seit langem sehr
effizient mit seinen Umweltgütern und
sie reden immer in der Vergangenheit ja
das wird ja nicht zur Kenntnis genommen
ich habe ja den Eindruck dass wir das
nicht wertschätzen man hat ja fast den
Eindruck dass Industrie in Deutschland
so etwas das nimmt man noch hin aber wir
müssen um den Industrie in Deutschland
kämpfen und die Energiepolitik macht für
mich nicht den Eindruck dass sie das
wirklich tut die Rahmenbedingungen da
hat Herr Markwort für dich recht sind
für dich
an eine Voraussetzung für
Deindustrialisierung denn der Strompreis
von der Industrie ist ja noch viel
geringer als den Preis den sie genannt
haben dass der Weimar bei 5 Euro Cent
die Chinesen haben drei die Amerikaner
haben zwei aber jetzt ist er auch für
die Industrie bei 20 das hält keine
Industrie aus und Sie sehen es ja schon
bei BASF sie sehen es bei RWE die wander
in die USA und Sie sehen es bei Daimler
und das hat Folgen weil die
kettenbrechen es ist ja nicht nur die
39.000 Arbeitsplätze bei der BASF es
geht ja darum dass dann
die gesamten Folgen der
Verarbeitung von
Lösemitteln von
Arzneimitteln von Kunststoffen mit
wegbrechen und die Menschen die dort
ihren Arbeitsplatz verloren verlieren
die dann vorher aber zum Bäcker gegangen
sind zum Metzger gegangen sind und
plötzlich diese Preise nicht mehr
bezahlen können auch das können wir
gleich vertiefen bei uns ist heldörfer
der ja Geschäftsführer ist eine
Metzgerei in Bamberg ein
Traditionsunternehmen seit 70 Jahren was
bedeutet für sie made in Germany oder
was ist bei ihnen in der Küche made in
Germany
bei uns ist alles made in Germany
schwäbische Fleisch
alles
für unser Bauern wir machen unseren
Wäsche selber wir machen unser ein
bisschen was habe ich mitgebracht ne
hier können Sie ganz kurz sagen also
einmal die Leberknödel natürlich nicht
made in Germany made in Bamberg das
alles made in Bamberg was sie herstellen
aber auch das was dahinter steht die
Maschinen all das made in German made in
Germany Frau sie sind die ersten zehn
Jahre ihres Lebens noch in der DDR groß
geworden was ist mit dieser Prägung ihr
Blick auf made in Germany auf diesem
Marke na made in Germany ist ein Quali
ist ein Qualitätsversprechen natürlich
an alle Konsumenten an alle Verbraucher
aber
es ist immer noch so es ist immer noch
so ich bedauere zutiefst dass wir immer
weniger made in Germany finden in den
Regalen und bei den Herstellern aber es
ist vor allen Dingen auch ein Label in
der ganzen Welt ja es ist eine Medaille
die wir uns Umhängen konnten bisher mit
der wir in der ganzen Welt beeindruckt
und überzeugt haben und wir sind gerade
dabei das alles aufs Spiel zu setzen
gerade vieles Wort dein
Industrialisierung schon auch von Herrn
fahnhold sind sie damit am Ziel
nein also das ist glaube ich so dass wir
einfach auch darauf schauen müssen wie
bereiten wir uns eigentlich für die
Zukunft vor und ich glaube da dürfen wir
auch den Anschluss nicht verlieren ich
glaube
Industrie in Deutschland zu erhalten
heißt auch dass ich Industrie
transformieren muss um den Anschluss
nicht zu schaffen dass darf aber auf der
anderen Seite dann auch nicht dazu
führen dass die Transformation Leute
zurücklässt den Mittelstand zurücklässt
oder das dann bestimmte
Unternehmenskonzepte überhaupt keine
Zeit keine Möglichkeit mehr haben sich
auf die neue Zeit auf neue Technologie
auch einzustellen deswegen muss man
damit frühstmöglich anfangen damit man
am Ende nicht zu spät da steht und in
die Röhre guckt aber Transformation
bedeutet das erfahren heute einfach weg
also Autoindustrie zum Beispiel einfach
weg Chemieindustrie einfach raus aus
Deutschland weg Stahlindustrie
vielleicht möglicherweise auch im
Industrie in Deutschland bedeutet das
und die Transformation ja gerne wissen
will was die neue Industrie dann sein
soll und dass die neuen Arbeitsplätze
dann sein sollen wenn es jedenfalls Wind
und Solaranlagen sein soll dann kann ich
Ihnen sagen das findet ihr jetzt schon
in China statt wenn von den fünf größten
solarenherstellern sind vier in China
und von den Windkraftanlagen von den
zehn größten künftigen China und das hat
was mit Strompreisen zu tun das hat auch
natürlich mit Rohstoffpreisen zu tun
sondern auch was mit Arbeitskosten zu
tun und deswegen müssen wir uns wirklich
mit und das fängt an mit der Politik
hinsetzen und das nicht auf die leichte
Schulter nehmen 24 Prozent unseres
Bruttoinlandsprodukt hängt von der
Industrie ab das sind sechs Millionen
Arbeitsplätze die von der
energieabhängig sind deswegen sind auf
die leichte Schulter nehmen ja natürlich
also ich meine hat ja gesagt wir müssen
jetzt auch Transformationen haben Brüche
müssen wir in Kauf nehmen und wir Federn
das dann ab mit Kurzarbeitergeld das ist
doch nicht unsere Zukunft wir müssen
doch dafür sorgen dass gerade jeder
Arbeitsplatz in der Grundstoffindustrie
hier bleibt ich wiederhole mich weil
draußen wird es noch zu viel viel
schlimmeren Zuständen führen weil China
produziert rein mit Kohle ihre Energie
ja und wir hatten ja mal einen Mix der
war auch mit Kernenergie verbunden CO2
Arm den gehen wir auch auf also insofern
kann ich verstehen aufgrund der
Energiekrise dass die Bundesregierung
jetzt sagt wir müssen den doppelbums
machen wir machen 7 Euro Cent für die
Gas den gasdeckel und versuchen das auch
bei Strom das ist richtig nur es hat
keine Perspektive weil die Welt ändert
sich ja nicht am 24 oder 15 April wenn
sozusagen die Kernkraftwerke vom Netz
gehen bleibt die gleiche
Energieknappheit da bleibt die gleiche
gasknappheit das heißt wir haben die
Zeit verschlafen wir hätten längst die
letzten 8 Monate dafür sorgen müssen
dass wir unsere eigenen Erdgasvorräte
endlich anzapfen werden längst dafür
sorgen müssen dass auch die alten drei
Kernkraftwerke die ausgestellt worden
sind verlängert werden dann hätten wir
eine Möglichkeit dieses diese Brücke zu
gehen wir können nicht alle halbe Jahr
200 dann auf dem Tisch legen das wird
die Inflation wir haben 10,4%. noch
weiter anheizen deswegen wir müssen mal
zu den Ursachen unserer Krise und die
selbst gemacht die meistgestellte Frage
in meine Richtung von
Mittelständlern Handwerkern ist immer
die warum machen die das in der
Bundesregierung so warum treffen die
Entscheidungen die uns so viel Schaden
zubereiten und ich finde Politik gute
Politik beginnt immer beim Betrachten
der Wirklichkeit und das was wir im
Moment erleben hat nichts mit der
Wirklichkeit zu tun es ist eine es sind
Entscheidungen die Vorbeigehen an dem
was unternehmen was die Menschen in
diesem Land tatsächlich brauchen und das
ist der Vorwurf den ich auch der
Bundesregierung mache und damit auch den
Grünen Herr Marquardt es gab mehrere
Fragen warum machen sie das so kommt die
Frage aus dem Wahlkreis von Frau Schimke
und erfahrenhold fragt sie ganz offen ja
ja Transformation ist ja gut und schön
aber welche Industrie wird es schön
meinen sie dann in Zukunft na gut wir
haben jetzt einen kurzfristig einfach
das Problem dass wir über Jahre uns
abhängig gemacht haben von einem Partner
der überhaupt kein Partner war ich
glaube da sind wir uns einig da müssen
wir mit einer Situation umgehen in der
es ja nicht weltweit einen gasmangel
gibt mit einmal sondern in der wir eben
einfach nicht die Infrastruktur haben um
das Gas kurzfristig von woanders her zu
bekommen was dann eben auch die Preise
so in die Höhe treibt der Grund für die
hohen Preis ist ja nicht Robert Habeck
Friedrich Merz Christian Lindner oder so
soll das Vladimir Putin und
das ist sind früher regiert dann die uns
in dieser Abhängigkeit geführt haben da
können wir ein Haken dran machen und das
geht nicht oder kaum auf Ihr Konto auf
das grüne Konto jetzt war aber in der
Situation wo wir dringend die Gaspreise
runter drücken müssen genau in der
Industrie dafür sorgen müssen dass
Energie bezahlbar ist dass wir bei
Metzgermeister in Bamberg dafür sorgen
müssen dass Energie bezahlbar ist und
die Menschen fragen sich auch in
Wahlkreis von Frau Schinkel tun sie
alles dafür damit der Preis dann das tun
also ehrlicherweise
also was zu lange gedauert hat ist die
Entscheidung wirklich viel Geld in die
Hand zu nehmen um kurzfristig die
Gaspreise so zu deckeln dass also
eigentlich rentabel Unternehmen dann mit
einmal nicht mehr weiter passieren
können dass sie eigentlich einmal vor
Existenzängsten stehen obwohl wir jetzt
eigentlich eine Brücke bauen können mit
Geld das in die Hand zu nehmen ist
glaube ich richtig die 200 Milliarden
jetzt aber auch schon die anderen
entlastungspakete und was wir dann jetzt
schaffen müssen ist das in der Tat wir
können das nicht jedes Jahr machen wäre
ich Volkswirtschaft soll das bezahlen
sondern dass wir dann eben die Gaspreise
wieder auf man kann sagen natürliche Art
und Weise so gering halten dass ich
bestimmte Modelle von Industrie auch so
darauf einstellen kann aber Herr
Marquardt dann ist doch BASF schon raus
dann haben die hier die Arbeitsplätze
schon gestrichen dann ist der
Metzgereibetrieb in Bamberg halt schon
dicht also ich sage ja mein Nachbar
heißt der beinahe wie ich aber trotzdem
bin ich der Meinung die Grünen sind die
fache sehr der deutschen Politik die
sagen wir machen alles besser die setzen
sich moralisch aufs
und sie schaffen den Kernenergie Abwehr
fahren heute hat gesagt 15 April das ist
das Samstag nach Ostern da werden die
Kern entkraftwerk ganz stillgelegt ist
dann die Energiekrise vorbei natürlich
nicht die anderen Nationen gehen rein
wir gehen raus sind auch das Thema
Fracking also wir sind pharisäerhaft und
sagen wir wollen keine Kernkraft auf wir
kaufen Sie im Rest von Europa wir wollen
kein Fracking weil wir das für ekelhaft
halten kaufen aber teures anderswo
gefrecktes Gas ich benutze mal ist es
Wort um uns damit zu erinnern dass es
unmöglich ja und wir vertreiben die
deutsche Industrie aus dem Land und an
jedem Arbeitsplatz hängt ja auch eine
Familie dann muss er sich mal vorstellen
das geht tief in den deutschen Wohlstand
hinein wenn wir da nicht eine Bremse
ziehen und sie machen alles mit in
Berlin mit der FDP
sie lassen den laufen also ich bin
natürlich ein unabhängiger freier
liberaler und bin nicht Mitglied dieser
Ampel mir tut der Christian Lindner leid
weil er mit diesen zwei
eigentumsfeindlichen Parteien dass ich
rumquälen muss ja ein paar Sachen
durchgesetzt wir wollten diese Ampel
nicht das ist aber kein Menschen
mitgemacht jetzt ist er Finanzminister
ganz dummerweise und ich glaube keiner
mit dem man richtig Mitleid haben muss
er trägt jeder Entscheidung mit ja
immerhin schafft er jetzt die kalte
Progression ab weil viele BürgerInnen
Atomkraftwerken 50 april ist es
macht für die FDP mal eben schlanken Fuß
und sagt na ja anscheinend aber es ist
das kleine Verdienst der FDP das
wenigstens die Verlängerung bis auf
diesen Sonntag nach Ostern durchgesetzt
wurde das ist mir überhaupt nicht genug
groß aber ohne Design sich wirklich um
das Land zu sorgen aber Sorgen
im Moment erleben in Deutschland ist
doch ein hochgradiger politischer
Skandal
Minister Habeck hat in seinem Hause
zusammen mit Ministerin Lemke den
Weiterbetrieb der Atomkraftwerke prüfen
lassen das Ergebnis wurde vorweggenommen
ich finde das das ist doch das ist doch
da muss doch sofort Konsequenzen gezogen
werden
weil dieser Bundesregierung der ist
nicht länger tragbar er hat gelogen er
und Frau Lemke haben gelogen die expert
wenn es geprüft wird und es wird gar
nicht ernsthaft geprüft sondern es steht
hinten auf der Seite schon ach der
Beschluss wir steigen auch die Grünen
haben wir tausende von Posten besetzt in
den Ämtern hat mit Trittin angefangen
und auch da habe ich halt überall seine
grünen Leute reingetan und ich habe ja
glaube ich in einer springerzeitung
gelesen dass fies sogar die letzten
ökonomisch denkenden von Vernunft
geprägten Beamten im
Wirtschaftsministerium gegen Habeck
votiert haben aber das wurde unterdrückt
noch mal sie spielen nicht Sie
persönlich aber ihre Farbe ihre gelbe
Farbe spielt das ja alles mit im nein
nein es wurde das tut mir jetzt muss ich
schon mal sagen ja wir haben es sehr
schwer genug in diesem 1 soweit zu zwei
Spiel die FDP hat dafür gesorgt dass
wenigstens bis 15 April diese drei
Kernkraftwerken weiterlaufen
noch mal anfangen wer ich bin dafür dass
wir noch mal darauf anfangen die Debatte
kommt wieder die brettstäbe müssen
gekauft werden
Marquardt auf die den Vorwurf von Frau
Schimke die sagt der Minister hat
gelogen der ist nicht tragbar in dieser
Regierung er hat den Beschluss schon
gekannt obwohl es gar nicht geprüft war
es wurde ja geprüft und nun kann man da
das Design dieser Studie sich lange
anschauen und schauen ich habe jetzt
keine ernsthafte Kritik davon von der
wissenschaftlichen Seite mitbekommen ich
habe mitbekommen dass das was die
Kernkraft zu leisten im Stande ist
momentan genutzt wird der Einfluss auf
den Preis ist marginal momentan mit
diesen drei Kernkraftwerke
aber das haben wir doch gesehen
gefroren hat gegen die Preise so runter
das allein das Signal hat die Preise
nach unten bewegt und wir müssen doch
wissen das ist die preiswerteste in der
stromerzeugungsform in Deutschland wenn
Sie die wegnehmen dann schieben sie die
Gaskraftwerke natürlich in der merit
order nach links und dann steigen wir
die Preise explosiv an aber wichtig ist
Energiemanager der jetzt auch nicht der
totale Kernkraft fällig das will ich
schon mal sagen ich finde wir müssen
auch für die Erneuerbaren sorgen aber
man macht sich nicht ehrlich weil sie
müssen sich ja mal anschauen in der Zeit
wo jetzt habe ich dran ist sind jetzt
gerade mal
3000 Megawatt Windenergie angemeldet
worden fürs nächste Jahr obwohl die
Gesetze so entschlackt worden sind und
das Naturschutzgesetz ja wirklich
zerfleddert worden ist
3000 es hat einen Grund warum weil
nämlich mittlerweile auch die Preise für
Windenergie massiv ansteigen die
Materialkosten steigen die Kapitalkosten
steigen ist und jetzt müssen sie mal
sich vorstellen was das bedeutet das
heißt im ganzen nächsten Jahr kommen
7000 Megawatt schlappe Megawatt 7000
Terawattstunden Entschuldigung 7000
Terabyte Stunden ans Netz das ist ein
Fünftel der Kernenergie die wir am 15
April abstellen das wird nicht gut gehen
das wird nicht funktionieren und
deswegen muss man sich ehrlich machen
und ich finde das erste was man machen
muss ist auch dann zu denjenigen die
einem jetzt Gas liefern können nicht so
arrogant hinzugehen ich meine er war ein
Catan hat gesagt also ich brauche für
sieben Jahre Gas und dann hat er ihm
gesagt nee wenn wir jetzt ein neues Feld
machen und dann noch ein LNG Terminal
bauen dann brauchen wir dann 20
jahreswetter dem Scheich gesagt brauche
ich das nicht mehr weil in sieben Jahren
wollen wir aus dem Gas raus weil wir
wollen ja CO2-frei sein das gleiche hat
er in Israel gemacht ja die israelische
Regierung sogar mehr oder weniger
beleidigt immer gesagt hat also wenn das
drei Jahre dauert dann brauche ich nicht
mehr denn dann sind wir sowieso schon
raus dann in Kanada das gleiche da hat
er gesagt sie sind immer Wasserstoff das
heißt also
Elefant den haben wir überhaupt gar
nicht gesehen Elefant im Raum ist hier
wir haben in Deutschland Erdgas Vorräte
für 20 bis 40 Jahre und jetzt kommt
natürlich jedem im weg weil er denkt
verdammt noch mal ich weiß auch dass in
USA geschludert worden ist da sind
Bohrlöcher gemacht worden und die sind
nicht mal hinter verfüllt worden der Gas
das Methan jetzt noch aus das muss man
natürlich anständig machen wir können es
aber anständig machen die nehmen auch
Chemikalien die können heute schon was
machen oder
sagen sie können heute Fracking machen
ohne Chemikalien einmal das muss doch
möglich sein in Deutschland dieses
Tracking Verbot endlich auf diese das
ist wirklich der Ingenieure und
Techniker wird dieses Fracking bei uns
besser machen aber sicher ja aber sicher
ich möchte gerne noch mal sind kleineren
ganz kurz machen weil er der ist mit
seiner Farbe der hier regiert also sind
sie überzeugt
ich glaube dass wir beim Tracking
einfach die Situation haben dass das
ähnlich wie die Atomkraft Diskussion
momentan eine totale Scheinlösung ist
also man kann so tun als würde das jetzt
große Probleme lösen die Probleme kann
man aber viel besser einfacher und
günstiger anders lösen also zum einen
mit dem Ausbau der Erneuerbaren wo sie
ja auch sagen sie sind nicht dagegen zum
anderen auch indem wir eben jetzt über
die nächsten Jahre auch schauen wie
können wir unsere gaskapazitäten über
LNG Terminals so gewinnen dass wir dann
auch später den Switch machen können und
auch Wasserstoff setzen können mit
diesem LNG bei mir jeden Tag viele viele
Unternehmen
und dann haben wir jetzt im Winter weil
wir aktuell
für diesen Winter also es ist ja so dass
wir jetzt wenn sie über Fracking
diskutieren dass die Diskussion also wir
hätten sie jetzt eine Mehrheit in der
Bundesregierung würden sie mit dem
Tracking anfangen wann würde dieses
Tracking Gasthaus da sein und die würden
sie das alles besser angefangen Waren
werden nach der dem Einmarsch der Russen
hätte das nach Aussagen der Experten die
wissen genau wo es liegt dass wir sein
ja wäre das erste Gas gefördert worden
wir werden jetzt im nächsten Jahr diesen
Winter gebe ich ihn zu wer das schwierig
geworden dafür ist ja auch die
gaspreisbremse aber die Gaspreise Bremse
führt nicht in die Zukunft das heißt
wenn wir angefangen werden hätten wir im
nächsten Winter denn der nächste Winter
kommt bestimmt und dann sind die
gasschläger leer
dass wenn man nicht von vorne rein auf
die letzte Seite geschrieben hat wie das
Ergebnis dieser Prüfung ist es ernsthaft
geprüft hätte dass jetzt dann genügend
Zeit gewesen wäre um eben an diese
zusätzlichen Gasreserven ranzukommen
also wenn ihr gerade über Fracking oder
vom Kraft über beides reden wir also
einfach erhebliche Bedenken dass das
wirklich eine Art ist mit der Natur so
umzugehen dass am Ende nicht das
Trinkwasser in Gefahr ist dass die
Gegenden in denen das passiert dann mit
einmal also man kann jetzt sagen nein
aber es ist doch so dass in den USA was
passiert
paul-geschichten den Fehler war noch mal
auf einer einfachere Dimension kommen
wir können ja hier keine Windräder bauen
das dauert da gibt es 1000 Probleme aber
ich kenne
ich kenne einen Menschen der möchte sich
Photovoltaik aufs Dach machen zwei Jahre
dauert das Genehmigung antragsfest wenn
die das dem Büro diese kleinbürokratie
abgeschafft werde hätten wir soweit
tausende Leuten die innerhalb von sechs
Wochen
Sonnenenergie hätten und würden damit
den Energiemarkt erleichterten sie aber
immer noch nachts keinen Strom aber das
ist schon weg
retten möglicherweise nicht mehr den
Betrieb von Den Helder vom das noch
einmal ganz konkret zu machen was haben
sie bisher an Energiekosten gehabt und
was haben sie jetzt im Zuge dieser
Energiekrise an Kosten wir haben immer
2000 Euro monatlichen Abschlag gehabt
jetzt seit Mai 4.500 also mehr als
verdoppelt und zum Ende des Jahres ist
unter der Tarifvertrag Stromvertrag
gekündigt worden
dann wird es noch teurer FIFA was würde
das bedeuten für die Waren die sie
anbieten also zum Beispiel
Leberkässemmel
Spaß bei ihnen 180 momentan und es
müsste was kosten damit sie daran
verdienen müsste 350 bis 4 Euro
verdienen jemand in Bamberg noch zahlen
kein Mensch das heißt sie sind jetzt
schon im Grunde Oberkante Unterlippe
wenn Sie das Essen teurer machen sie
verdienen vor allen Dingen am Catering
bzw an dem Essen was Sie kochen sonntags
für eine Stammkundschaft wenn Sie das
teurer machen würden da wird keiner mehr
kommen
wird keine mehr kommen weil die Leute
das Geld sitzt immer so locker wann
werden sie schließen
31.12 der letzte Tag
nach 70 Jahren die ist diesen Betrieb
dort gibt das heißt ab da werden Ihre
Kunden wo kaufen beim Discounter oder
was ist die Alternative es gibt immer
weniger Metzgereien bei uns in der um
die Ecke nur noch ein und der ist auch
ziemlich weit weg Bamberg Ost ist
eigentlich großes Gebiet ist aber dann
keine Metzgerei mehr den Grünen ist im
Grunde genommen die Energiewende
wichtiger als das Schicksal dieser ist
das so das wäre jetzt die Frage gewesen
Herr Marquardt also geht ums jetzt
problemisch zu sagen die Rostbratwurst
von den helldörfer auf ihre auf Ihr
Konto nein es ist so dass wir auf der
einen Seite eben eine und das muss man
glaube ich in solchen Diskussionen
können wir alles im Detail diskutieren
aber dass wir eine große Krise haben die
nicht von den Grünen oder der FDP oder
der CDU gemacht wurde völlig klar dass
wir auf die reagieren müssen dass wir
diese 200 Milliarden hast du spät die
Hand genommen haben das war ein Fehler
aus meiner Sicht dieser Bundesregierung
da müssen sie aber vielleicht nicht bei
den Grünen schauen wer daran schuld ist
dass man so lange diskutieren musste bis
man dort unterstützen kann bis man auch
unterstützen kann dass die Energiepreise
diskutieren nicht darüber wer den Krieg
begonnen hat das ist die Sache die klar
ist Putin hat den Kriegen die Frage ist
ob wir darauf richtig reagiert haben
Bundesregierung müssen dass das nicht
passiert ist liegt aber nicht an den
Grünen aber die Energiekrise das muss
man schon sagen wir können nicht alles
auf Putin schieben nicht die
Energiepreise stiegen schon in 21 an
warum weil die europäische Politik sie
sitzen in Europa-Parlament gesagt hat
wir wollen einen Kampf gegen Kohle Öl
und Gas führen es wurde der
Verbrennungsmotor verboten 35 da haben
die Grünen sich jetzt richtig kräftiger
jubeln sie ja
steigen und das ist steigen aus etwas
ist unser Problem ja wir reißen unser
Haus aus haben wir das neue noch gar
nicht gebaut und wenn vorstellen dass
sie diese Energie die zur Mobilität
nötig ist durch Strom ersetzen der durch
welchen Strom der bitteschön da ist dann
auch noch die Kernenergie Weg die Kohle
will man hier auch nicht haben anstatt
sich wirklich mal ohne ideologisch an
die Sache zu gehen wir können
Kohlekraftwerke machen in Brandenburg
schon mal gezeigt worden in Spremberg
Kohlekraftwerke mit CO2-Abscheidung also
grüne Kohlekraftwerke das wäre die erste
Möglichkeit sagen wir lassen die
Kohlekraftwerke wir habe ich ja jetzt
macht wir lassen weiterlaufen aber dann
brauchen wir oben eine Abscheidung da
sind sie auch klimaneutral will man aber
nicht ist Deutschland verboten
Fracking ist verboten aber auch die
Abscheidung von CO2 ist Verbot das
nächste ist Erdgas muss man machen und
das drittes Laufzeitverlängerung und das
ist alles von Europa schon vorher
eingetütet worden die
Emissionszertifikate haben den Strom in
Deutschland bei Gas verdoppelt bei Kohle
verdreifacht das heißt seine Verdopplung
ist schon passiert da waren die Russen
noch gar nicht da ja das ist Männer
passiert das kann man in den Statistiken
sehen und wir müssen uns ehrlich machen
es ist vieles selbst vor uns verursacht
indem wir eine Politik gemacht haben wie
gesagt wir wollen raus aus dem CO2 da
kann man ja
sich sehr für sehr sehr verständigen
aber doch bitte nicht in zehn Jahren
aber darum gehen politisch geworden die
wir sind zu schnell zu hastig und
zerstören etwas während wir das andere
noch nicht aufgebaut haben
gemeinsam bewerbsfähig jetzt gucken wir
gemeinsam auf unseren Industriestandort
wir sehen jetzt die Schreckensmeldung
von BASF der Kanzler wird morgen da sein
und wird erklären warum so viele
Arbeitsplätze dort voraussichtlich
verloren gehen werden wen wird das noch
treffen wovon gehen sie aus große
Unternehmen
wird uns alle treffen machen wir uns
doch nichts vor das ist doch nicht nur
ein Unternehmen macht dicht oder geht
weg und dann war es das jetzt für ein
paar hundert Mitarbeiter nein es trifft
doch die gesamte Gesellschaft wir haben
doch alle miteinander zusammen wir sind
vernetzt wir konsumieren wir fahren in
den Urlaub es können keine Preise mehr
kalkuliert werden es wird die gesamte
Wirtschaft
wir haben die höchsten Strompreise in
der ganzen Welt in G20 überall und mehr
als die Hälfte davon ich glaube 53
Prozent sind Steuern und Abgaben da muss
man was tun alle anderen
wettbewerbsländer die lachen sich ins
Fäustchen die deutschen Unternehmen
gehen überall hin überall ist es
günstiger da muss die Regierung was
machen runter mit den Steuern wenn sie
jetzt im Moment ein Topmanager werden
Herr Marquardt bei einem der führenden
Unternehmen beim großen Stahlunternehmen
großen Automobilunternehmen und sie
sehen im Moment die Entwicklung der
Energiepreise könnten sie es überhaupt
verantworten gegenüber ihnen
Mitarbeitern vor allen Dingen aber
gegenüber den Aktionären hier weiter zu
produzieren
ach die Aktionäre haben es doch gut die
Aktionäre können überall investieren in
Amerika und wenn BASF nach China kommt
und geht dann habe ich eine BASF Aktie
dies genauso wäre der Aktionär überhaupt
nicht das Problem ist ein
internationaler Anleger gott sei dank
der deutschen auch der kann in der
ganzen Welt anlegen
ja genau
mal ausklammern aus der Sorge aber die
Mitarbeiter ich fürchte aber wenn ich
ein Unternehmen habe so wie Seins muss
ich verantwortlich für meine Mitarbeiter
denken aber sie sind Top-Manager sie
sind für den Börsenkurs verantwortlich
erfahren heute sie kennen genau diese
Situation jetzt sehen sie die
Entwicklung der Energiepreise würden sie
das in dieser Situation verantworten und
zu sagen andere die nächsten 10 Jahre
immer weiter in Deutschland andere
Antwort darauf geben sehen Sie ich kann
das verstehen dass 2,2 Milliarden mehr
Kosten bei der BASF dass er Bruder
Müller sagt das kann ich nicht weiter
leisten ich kann nicht miese machen dann
dann sind wir dann ist das Unternehmen
in der substanzgefährdet also muss ich
abbauen hat er gesagt ich will Kosten
einsparen was der heißt am Ende aber
was man aber schon erwarten muss von
unseren industrieführern ist dass sie
ihren Mund vielleicht mal ein bisschen
früher aufmachen die deutsche Industrie
hat doch viel zu lange diesen Trubel in
Berlin zugeschaut das ist doch nicht
gestern erst passiert wer hat denn 2011
Frau Merkel gesagt lasse das mal lieber
mit dem Ausstieg wer hat den 2017 als
der Kohleausstieg beschlossen worden ist
das die ostdeutsche Braunkohle zerstört
wird wer hat denn da gesagt das wollen
wir eigentlich nicht
wir haben alle geschrieben ich nicht ich
war immer dabei habe gesagt das ist ein
verhängnisvoller Kurs und deswegen
erwarte ich das von unseren
industrieführern die haben Mitarbeiter
in der Obhut in der Verantwortung für
deren Arbeitsplätze das erwarte ich
nicht
genau der Gedanke sie regieren mit und
gucken im Grunde dabei zu wie diese
Unternehmen gerade dicht machen wie
Betriebe pleite gehen
in der fdp-rolle sage ich halt wir
leisten Widerstand aber ich gebe dem
fahren heute direkt allein reicht nicht
nein
teilweise den Grünen in den Arsch
kriechen entschuldigen sie ja ach das
ist doch grauenvoll was man dass sie
nicht ich denke mal voller schockierung
an den audi-Chef der hat glaube ich muss
man einmal sagen was der gesagt hat
Markus Dussmann der vergangenen Woche in
der Süddeutsche Zeitung haben wir das
Zitat vorliegen vom Audi Chef der
begeistert sich nämlich als autobos
plötzlich für autofreie Sonntage und
sagt genau das um uns also in
Deutschland besser einzustimmen auf die
Lage und die Notwendigkeit des Sparens
könnte es wieder Sinn ergeben autofreie
Tage zu machen so wie in den 70er Jahren
kann auf den Autobahn das hat doch noch
dazu geführt ja dann wenn sonntags frei
kann der Rennrad fahren auf der Autobahn
das ist ein Skandal der gehört davon
Audi abgelöst unintelligible schädigend
für Audi und Geschäftsschädigung für die
ganze Familie außerdem da kommt ja das
Wort vor Auto frei da könnte ich ja
sagen doch um frei vor nichts da das ist
Verbot das ist Gängelung die Menschen
kaufen sich ein Auto von ihrem ersparten
Geld um am Samstag Sonntag zum
Fußballverein zu fahren oder die
Wirtschaft oder Freunde Verwandten
besuchen da brauche ich keine Maske im
Auto in in der Eisenbahn und ich kann
muss mich nicht nach Fahrpläne richten
das Auto ist ein Symbol der Freiheit und
da kommt ein Vorstandsvorsitzender eines
großen audi-konzerns ja und sagt
autofeiertage können nur die Sonntage
sein also ich habe ja mit Leuten von
Audi gesprochen die wurden ja die
Verkäufer sind ja stocksauer die Grünen
freuen sich oder über den Satz vom Audi
Boss das kann man ich muss ehrlich sein
und sagen dass ich also das
ist eine Debatte die mich nicht
sonderlich interessiert ich glaube das
ist nicht viel hilft
Autofahrer interessiert das passiert
jedem der sonntags halt auch mal Auto
fährt ja die Kinder zum Fußball fährt
der Verwandte besucht am Wochenende der
mit der Familie unterwegs ist
um ehrlich zu sein glaube ich dass der
Audi Chef sich da auf andere Probleme
konzentrieren muss ich bin auch kein
großer Fan dieser Idee von Autos also
meiner so heiße sitzen da in ihrem
Brüssel und im Straßburg und sagen
ja das ist ja neben mir und wissen nicht
wie die deutschen Autofahrer denken und
fühlen die haben sich diese Symbol der
Freiheit gekauft die wollen nicht
geklingelt werden brauchen sie sonntags
sehr Autobahn natürlich Catering was
würde man bei ihnen in der Stadt im Ort
sagen wenn man ihnen sagt also ab heute
machen wir hier autofreien Sonntag schön
kann schwierig für Geschäft Leute ja das
ist eine Art von wohlstandsverwale also
die sich hier breit macht das muss man
schon sagen nicht denn man wenn so über
Probleme wir sind in einer der
schwersten energiekrisen und ein Manager
sagt auch lass mal den den Gott lieben
Mann sein das das ist aber ein ein
Zeichen für unser Feuer also ich würde
sofort feuern und würde sagen das
erwarten auch die Kunden also ich glaube
dass ich nie wieder ein Audi kaufen
würde wenn solange der Mann da ist ja
ich war auf jeden Fall das ist
nicht viel ändern das heißt also am Ende
muss das schon eine eine breitere
Wirkung haben ich habe deswegen etwas
gemacht ich habe eine Initiative in die
Welt gerufen rettet die Industrie aber
gibt's Aufkleber die kann man sich
googeln rettet unsere Industrie rettet
unsere Industrie und wenn jeder das an
sein Auto klebt anstatt atomkraft nein
danke das war ja gestern
sozusagen völlig altmodisch rettet
unsere Industrie
jeder wird Sie den Aufkleber tragen
gerettet und auch merken dass die
Menschen für ihre Industrie eintreten ja
ich würde den Aufkleber glaube ich neben
den atomkraft nein danke Aufkleber
machen aber ja dann schon widerspricht
sich das in diesen Zeiten
runterklappen bei mir nicht dran kleben
weil ich glaube das unterscheiden wir
uns eben das ist äh kann man auch nichts
mehr Atomkraft also überbrücken ich
finde das interessant weil das sozusagen
jetzt als grüne Idee gilt die Atomkraft
abzuschaffen aber beschlossen haben das
ja nicht die Grünen was allerdings
passiert ist ist dass wir die Zeit
verlinke das geschlossen haben
Merkel ein Solo ja ich glaube nicht dass
sie es ganz alleine war ähm es gab
damals natürlich so überwältigende mehr
wahrscheinlich
zustimme ist dass wir 2011 gesagt haben
wir wollen aus der Atomkraft raus halte
ich für eine sehr richtige Entscheidung
aber mit der Entscheidung hängt
natürlich zusammen dass man dann die
nächsten Jahre auch intensiv daran
arbeiten muss wenn alles auf diesen
Ausstieg vorzubereiten das glaube ich in
den letzten elf Jahren einfach nicht
passiert
Frau Schimke und die Herren Markwort und
fahrenhold und helldörfer haben sich
aufgeregt über die Aussagen des Audi
Bosses die Wahrheit die offenbar
dahinter steckt ist ja dem ist es
relativ wurscht mittlerweile was der
deutsche Autofahrer was der deutsche
Markt macht der verdient sein Geld
sowieso schon längst vor anders na gut
das kann jeder von uns bewerten wie er
mag ich glaube wir werden von der
deutschen Wirtschaft keine Revolution zu
erwarten haben ne aber was wir was wir
was wir sehr wohl was wir sehr wohl
erwarten dürfen auch von unseren
Unternehmens Lenkern und Managern ist
dass sie die Interessen ihres
Unternehmens vertreten und die ihre
Mitarbeiter
sein Interesse kann ja nicht sagen wir
machen jetzt komplett autofreie Woche
und die deutschen brauchen keine Autos
funktionieren finde diese Aussage ist
ein Stück weit Ausdruck von von
lebensferne von realitätsferne von dem
schweben auf einer bestimmten Ebene von
dem Wunsch Akzeptanz und an zu
generieren bei den mächtigen bei der
Regierung aber es hat sehr sehr wenig zu
tun mit den Menschen für die diese Autos
gebaut werden aber stimmt das dass dem
Audi Boss und möglicherweise auch den
BMW-Chef von dem VW-Chef mittlerweile
der deutsche Kunde eigentlich wurscht
sein kann das spielt einfach keine Rolle
mehr naja ich würde sagen der Deutsche
im Allgemeinen den Eindruck kann man
bekommen wenn man draußen auf die Straße
geht sich mit den Menschen unterhält
sich mit dem Metzger vor Ort unterhält
dann ist das Stimmungsbild ein komplett
anderes als das was sie aus diesem
Chefetagen zu hören bekommen na gut
erhalten wir aber auch nicht nur mit dem
deutschen Markt die Arbeitsplätze in
Deutschland die Industrie ist schon
darauf ausgerichtet auch Sachen zu
exportieren deswegen finde ich jetzt
unabhängig von dieser Aussage ich habe
ja gesagt ich mache mir den nicht so
eigen finde ich es auch wichtig dass man
natürlich den Blick für die Außenwelt
auch außerhalb von Deutschland nicht
verliert und dass man sich auch anschaut
wie können wir denn Produkte generieren
in welchem Bereich auch immer die
konkurrenzfähig bleibt und
konkurrenzfähig sind auch für das
ausländische Geschäft und da merke ich
wenn man sich jetzt hier aufregt gerne
über 2035 Verbrenner aus man muss sagen
da werden weiter noch Verbrenner fahren
aber
es ist so dass die meisten es ist so
dass die meisten Unternehmen ob es
Daimler Audi oder VW sind das jetzt
nicht als extreme Gängelung empfinden
sondern schon auch sagen dass es
eigentlich gut dass wir mal eine
Zielvorstellung haben und die werden sie
auch einhalten können ihre Verbrenner
halt woanders und auf dem chinesischen
verkauft das in dem kleinen deutschen
Markt hin und produzieren weiter
Verbrenner für Kinder aber ich glaube an
nicht nur an das sollte Dichter und
Denker sondern auch an das Volk der
Ingenieure und Techniker und ich bin
Technologie offen wer weiß was bis dahin
2035 noch entwickelt wird das Benzin
wird anders wird günstiger es gibt noch
so viele technische Innovationen in
diesem deutschen Volk die werden von der
Politik einfach weggewischen ich bin
misstrauisch wenn Politiker so wie ich
die so wenig von Ingenieurskunst
verstehen
ein Datum festlegen 2035 also ich hoffe
dass es noch mal überholt wird und wir
wissen ja alle refuels mehr CO2 Produkt
also E-Autos mehr CO2 produzieren als
selbst ein Diesel nicht weil die
Batterie die dann in China produziert
wird erstmal sozusagen
deprimierenden Stimmung hier rausgezogen
hat und trotzdem müssen wir gleich noch
mal ganz fokussiert über ihre
bevorstehende ja Insolvenz muss man
sagen sprechen dort in Bamberg aus dem
Betrieb zurückziehen zumindest nach über
70 Jahren
traditionsmetzgerei das gleich nach
einer kurzen Pause hier
[Musik]
made in Germany war es das fragen wir
heute Abend um haben unter anderem zu
Gast Oliver heldörfer der
Metzgereibetrieb führt in Bamberg noch
führt wenn man am 31.12 dieses Jahres an
Silvester ist dann Schluss wird die
letzte Wurst verkauft in Bamberg in
Ihrem Betrieb auch wegen der so stark
gestiegenen Energiekosten was macht den
Unterschied zwischen ihrer Wurst und
einer discounterwurst
unsere Wurst ist noch alles selber
gemacht wir kaufen fast nichts dazu gibt
es auch sehr seltene in der heutigen
Zeit
wir machen sehr viel Gemüse im Darm dass
sie mir her also mit sehr viel Gemüse
wir sehen gerade einmal den Blick in
ihren Betrieb rein das heißt dort wird
Schluss sein in genau zwei Monaten sie
haben den Zettel schon draußen an die
Tür gehängt das dann eben der Hammer
fällt wir haben vor wenigen Wochen den
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck gehört
der bei der Kollegin Sandra Maischberger
sich so geäußert hat auf die Frage ob
Deutschland eine Pleitewelle bevorsteht
können wir uns noch einmal gemeinsam
anschauen helldörfer das war da die
Antwort von Robert Habeck auf die Frage
von Sandra Maischberger
ich kann mir vorstellen dass
bestimmte Branchen
einfach erstmal aufhören zu produzieren
nicht insolvent werden aber ich meine
ich im Moment komme ich nicht mehr dazu
Brötchen einzukaufen und
geschweige denn morgens in Ruhe zu
frühstücken aber ich weiß aus alter Welt
dass die Brötchen bei Bäckern und die
Brötchen in den Discountern ungefähr
doppelt so teuer sind und wenn die
Preise relativ steigen dann erhöht sich
der Abstand und dann werden das sehen
wir ja jetzt überall das Leben die
darauf angewiesen sind dass die Menschen
Geld ausgeben Blumenläden Bioläden
Bäckereien gehören dazu dass die
wirkliche Probleme haben weil das eine
Kauf Zurückhaltung gibt und dann sind
die nicht insolvent automatisch aber sie
hören vielleicht auf zu produzieren was
haben Sie in dem Moment gedacht als sie
das gehört haben heldörfer
ja ich habe mir gedacht
ist das alles von der Politik kommt da
gar nichts wir kleinen werden eigentlich
im Stich gelassen
es kommen keine Hilfen und wenn sie
jetzt mal kommen sollen dann ist es zu
spät
also
und wenn man den Laden einmal zu hat
dann schreibt man da eigentlich noch mal
auf
was
ist ein realitätsferner Blödsinn und
weil sie immer auf der FDP rumhacken
will ich mal sagen der Liebling der
Grünen ist für diesen Unsinn fantastisch
geschont worden wenn der Lindner in
solchen Schwachsinn erzählt hätte wäre
die ganze medienbeute über ihn
hergefällen gefallen und hätte ihn
wahrscheinlich zum Rücktritt getrieben
das ist unglaublich sein
Wirtschaftsminister ein solches Stuss
erzählt Herr Marquardt was haben Sie in
dem Moment gedacht und jetzt sitzen wir
in Angesicht von den helldörfer der sagt
war die Hilfen kam zu spät das haben sie
ja auch gerade gesagt dass vieles zu
spät kam nur hier sind sozusagen eins
der Schicksale mit dem Tisch kann man
halt machen nichts
ja also ich glaube bei der Aussage war
weder die Aussage noch besonders nicht
besonders glücklich aber ich glaube auch
dass Robert Habeck über die Aussage
eigentlich nicht besonders glücklich war
ich glaube der Punkt auf den er hinaus
wollte ist faktisch richtig aber das
kann man natürlich sozusagen nicht als
Leitbild in die Politik übernehmen also
den Eindruck zu erwecken und ich glaube
nicht dass er das machen wollte sah egal
ob Betriebe produzieren oder nicht das
ist natürlich nicht richtig ich glaube
worauf wir hinaus wollte ist dass man
eben jetzt Hilfen braucht weil in
bestimmten Situationen und das passiert
auch normalerweise in bestimmten
betrieben aber es ist kein anderen
Gewerken so dass man eben nicht die
ganze Zeit produziert so das ist aber
bei Bäckereien beispielsweise anders
auch bei Metzgereien anders die
produzieren natürlich die ganze Zeit
sind keine Saisonbetriebe oder so
und da ist es ähm genau also ist die
Frage sozusagen jetzt können wir uns
noch mal die Maischberger Sendung
angucken aber wie kann man ihn
eigentlich helfen in der Situation das
ist die Frage die eigentlich
ja also ich weiß nicht ob es zu spät ist
ich weiß nicht kurz unterhalten
vielleicht und ich habe Robert Habeck
heute zum Beispiel vernommen er sagte
eigentlich müssten diese Hälften schon
ab ersten Januar gehen das ist zu spät
dass die Kommission vorschlägt wir
müssen gucken dass wir da schneller
werden das ist jetzt glaube ich das was
wir machen müssen so schnell wie möglich
so vielen Betrieben insbesondere auch
kleinen mittelständischen Unternehmen da
unter die Arme zu greifen damit sie über
diesen Winter kommen und wir dann noch
Zeit haben bis zum nächsten Mal die
haben sich auf die grüne auf die
Regierung verlassen die haben auch erst
im Laufe diese Energiekrise gehört wir
haben keinen Stromproblem und jetzt
sehen sie ihre stromabschläge auch ihre
Strom abgeschläge ihre gasabschläge und
sehen wir können den Betrieb gar nicht
mehr halten wir können so nicht mehr
arbeiten ja also dass das das ist das
blanke Entsetzen was ich dort
tatsächlich auch breit macht aber vor
allen Dingen auch das Unverständnis mit
was für Politikern wir es dazu tun haben
also
wo fehlt der Sach wo ist der
Sachverstand wo ist die Fachexpertise
wo ist die Entscheidungs der
entscheidungswille das zu tun was
tatsächlich nah liegt in dieser Krise
und ich meine wir haben schon im August
ein Viertel mehr an Insolvenzen in
Deutschland gehabt als im Vorjahresmonat
und dieser Trend geht weiter wir haben
in Deutschland für 23 eine Rezession
anders als in Frankreich oder in
Großbritannien es ist doch
offensichtlich dass die Entscheidungen
die in Deutschland getroffen werden
falsch sind weil anderen Ländern geht es
immer noch besser auch in dieser Krise
und das ist das was wir auch als
Opposition kritisieren wir brauchen
andere Entscheidungen wir brauchen jetzt
eine Überprüfung des Koalitionsvertrages
wir brauchen eine Überprüfung aller
Belastungen die in vergangenen als auch
in geplanten Gesetzen für die Wirtschaft
enthalten sind das muss alles auf den
Prüfstand und das kann ich nicht
erkennen
wir fahren heute wir brauchen einen
Wirtschaftsminister der für die
Arbeitsplätze kämpft natürlich und der
uns jetzt nicht wie in den letzten Tagen
geschehen erzählt dass die
gaspreisbremse möglicherweise an der
eu-scheitern wird unser Arbeitsminister
unser Wirtschaftsminister sagen sie
kämpft nicht genügend die Arbeitsplätze
wenn jemand die gaspreisbremse an der
25.000 Firmen wenn wir die 7 Cent nicht
kriegen das ist im halben Jahr Schicht
das heißt wir brauchen die und da da
hilft es mir nicht wenn der
Wirtschaftsminister sagt ja da gibt es
Schwierigkeiten in der EU und
möglicherweise kriegen wir das gar nicht
groß und dann machen wir einen
Antragsverfahren dann höre ich schon oh
Bürokratie das dauert noch länger da
muss es möglich sein auch mal in der EU
auf dem Putz zu hauen und zu sagen
dieses Europa hat die letzten Jahre von
der Lokomotive Deutschland gelebt und
jetzt möchten wir ganz gerne dass wir
unser Industrie helfen und das Verlangen
wir jetzt von euch die Franzosen haben
für ihre Industrie 4,5 Euro Cent
industriestrompreis die EU hat das
laufen lassen hat das akzeptiert jetzt
fangen wir an und sagen wir wollen
sieben machen beim Gas und da kommen die
EU ansagt ja das ist aber eine
Wettbewerbsverzerrung dann das müssen
wir mal schieben und dann sagt die
Regierung ja dann können wir nichts
ändern
und sagen erst kommt Deutschland und
dann kommt Europa hallo ihr wollt wie
klingt das für eine superparlamentarier
Herr Marquardt erst kommt Deutschland
dann kommt Europa sagt er fahren heute
also in der Tat ist es so dass
Frankreich Spanien Italien auch andere
Länder schon solche Pakete beschlossen
haben und dass ich davon ausgehe und ich
weiß es auch dass der
Wirtschaftsminister da nicht nur bei
Ursula von der Leyen aus der Partei von
Frau schimp gefragt was man gerade
machen darf sondern dass es da natürlich
auch ich weiß nicht sie haben gesagt auf
den putzsong gibt aber ich gehe fest
davon aus dass diese Bundesregierung in
der Lage ist und die gaspreisbremse dann
auch jetzt so durchzuführen das wird
passieren da bin ich fest von überzeugt
ich glaube dass man aber unabhängig
davon eben auch in dieser Krise schauen
muss und das ist vielleicht etwas
kontrainduiv weil man denkt die kümmern
zuerst mal um uns aber natürlich muss
man auch diese Krise jetzt auch diese
Erkenntnis dass wir uns auf falsche
Partner verlassen haben dazu nutzen das
Europa zusammenhält also es war
teilweise ja so dass wir uns gegenseitig
auf dem gaspreismarkt überboten haben
mit den EU-Ländern statt mal darüber zu
reden wie können wir gemeinsam unsere
Marktmacht auch nutzen und da deutlich
also die Frage ist dann nicht
Deutschland zuerst sondern die Frage ist
dann wie können wir eigentlich die Kraft
die Europa gemeinsam hat wenn alle
zusammenhalten dann auch nutzen um
schnell auch gut als Europa durch diese
Krise untergegangen also zu dem deutsche
Interessen müssen vorrangig vertreten
werden dazu Einsatz aber irgendwas zum
Frau schimp gesagt die fragt ja zurecht
nach dem Sachverstand der deutschen
Politiker da haben wir ja eine groteske
Situation ich glaube Ludwig Erhard war
es oder wer immer hat ja den Rat der
fünf weißen erfunden großartige deutsche
Ökonomen von allen Universitäten
Fachleute aller Art die machen Gutachten
und die werden weggeschmissen ja die
haben mir Vorschläge gemacht die sehr
gut sind die hat da habe ich und auch
vorherige Altmaier auch schon mal haben
die einfach weggewischt wofür hören wir
denn nicht warum hören wir nicht auf den
Sachverstand dieser Leute das ist doch
Grotes da würde ich die Kommission
auflösen wenn es nur Altpapier wird
wir leben in der tiefen Wirtschaftskrise
es hat jetzt jeder aus dieser
Perspektive aus seiner Perspektive
beschrieben und jetzt erleben wir
mittendrin eine flüchtlingskrise wieder
in diesem Winter Herr Marquardt
was glauben Sie wie die Deutschen da im
Moment drauf reagieren übernehmen wir
uns also ich glaube dass wir bei der
Situation ja momentan betrachten müssen
wer kommt da eigentlich wer ist dieses
Jahr gekommen und das sind zu 80%
Menschen aus der Ukraine ja vor allem
Frauen und Kinder und die haben
natürlich jetzt auch in einem Land wo es
nicht besonders viele Kapazitäten für
solche Katastrophenfälle gab und wo
keine resilienten Strukturen da waren
dann erstmal auch Unterkunft brauchen
müssen das war so dass viele privat
untergekommen sind das toll wie viele
Leute sich da engagiert haben die die
Gesellschaft auch mit dem Menschen aus
der Ukraine zusammengehalten hat wir
sehen jetzt aber dass diejenigen die
sonst auch noch kommen die kam die
letzten Jahre auch dann eben wenig Platz
finden und das ist auch in den Kommunen
wirklich wenig Möglichkeiten gibt dort
die Menschen anständig unterzubringen
wir wollen ja immer wieder für die Leute
die einfach sagen Mensch wir würden
gerne aber wir haben einfach keinen
Platz mehr wir haben keine Wohnung mehr
Frau Schinken sie werden das kennen aus
ihrem Wahlkreis aus den
nachbarwahlkreisen wie würden Sie die
Stimmung dort im Moment beschreiben
bei ja einer letztlich immer noch fahren
Willkommenskultur und aber gleichzeitig
bei einem ganz starken Gefühl Mensch wir
haben so große Probleme vor der Tür die
Stimmung wir schaffen das gar nicht also
wir erleben schon eine große Solidarität
in Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainern gegenüber
ohne Frage aber die Leute nehmen
natürlich auch zur Kenntnis dass wir
eine eine steigende Anzahl an illegaler
Migration haben in Deutschland und dass
wir vor allen Dingen eine
Bundesregierung haben die wirklich ein
Paradigmenwechsel in der
Migrationspolitik vor sich hat und den
hat sich auch vorzunehmen und auch
umzusetzen 12.000 etwa illegale
Migranten im Moment pro Monat Herr
Marquardt nehmen Sie das war ist das
ganz offen ein Thema in der
Bundesregierung oder ist das was was man
gerne gerne unter Tisch fallen lässt
nein also das nimmt man wahr und da muss
man sich auch anschauen aus welchen
Ländern kommen die Menschen die da
kommen das sind ja vor allem auch Länder
in den Krieg herrscht Syrien Afghanistan
zum Beispiel sind die
hauptherkunftsländer momentan es gibt
dann so einzelne Situationen wo man
jetzt auch glaube ich schnell
diplomatischen Druck braucht
beispielsweise ist so dass in Serbien
relativ viele Menschen aus Indien nach
Serbien kommen und dann über Österreich
auch weiterreisen dort Asylanträge
Stellen Menschen aus Indien bekommen am
Ende kein Asyl die haben auch das
rechten Asylantrag zu stellen aber muss
dann schnell jetzt mal mit Indien und
Serbien reden warum das eigentlich so
passiert dass es auch Teil einer man
kann sagen russischen Strategie dort
bestimmte Menschen in aber auch künftig
kein Asyl mehr um dauerhaftes
Bleiberecht in Deutschland zu bekommen
ist ja schon als geduldet da können sie
mit geringeren Anforderungen ein
bisschen Deutsch Sprachkenntnisse und
ein bisschen Integrationsbereitschaft
und schon können Sie in Deutschland
bleiben das ist das was die Ampel hat
ich bin froh dass sie das Thema mal
anschneiden weil ich glaube dass es in
den Medien und in der Politik zu klein
behandelt wird das Thema Migration da
wird in den Talkshows stundenlang über
diesen Ausrutscher von Friedrich Merz
geredet sozialtourismus richtig oder
falsch aber das Problem wird nicht
besprochen ich kenne viele Bürgermeister
und Landräte die sind verzweifelt die
illegalen sind das Problem
politisch verfolgt wird kriegt bei uns
Asyl dass sie dem Grundgesetz da steht
jeder zu aber unsere Nachbarn in Serbien
beinahe Nachbarn und der Schweiz die
schicken uns die Leute rüber da müssen
wir was gegen tun da muss die Regierung
die Grenzen zu machen gegen illegale
ist ihre parteischef zu still geworden
nachdem er da so gebascht wurde wegen
seines sozialtourismussatzes übrigens
also dieser Sendung wir sind überhaupt
nicht still wenn sie letzte
Bundestagsdebatte zu diesem neuen Gesetz
was da geplant ist verfolgt kann dann
haben sie sehr sehr deutlich gesehen wo
unsere Haltung ist also wir haben das
sehr sehr deutlich gemacht wir haben
genau gesagt wie erfolgreich oder eben
auch erfolglos die
Integrationsbemühungen waren wie hoch
der Integrationswille ist wie viel
Menschen auch tatsächlich arbeitslos
sind unter den hier lebenden Migranten
und
ausziehen ist das Friedrich Merz das in
dieser Sendung gesagt hat danach gepasht
wurde und dann das Thema für die Union
eigentlich erleben
in Deutschland überhaupt kein interess
daran diesen Problemen mal nachzugehen
und das mal zu untersuchen ich ganz
ehrlich ich rede ja auch mit den
Menschen in diesem Mann sie hören alles
sie hören alles sie haben große
Bemühungen
Integration zu fördern die Menschen zu
helfen sie haben aber auch ganz andere
Berichte sie sie hören und erleben alles
und ich führe diese Diskussionen täglich
aber wir können es nicht festmachen wir
können es nicht an Zahlen festmachen
weil in diesem Lande kein Interesse
daran besteht Probleme auf den Grund zu
gehen man will es nicht wissen und das
ist der Vorwurf den wir machen und an
der Aussage von also man kann über die
Aussage von Friedrich Merz sicherlich
streiten ob sie richtig platziert war ob
sie richtig formuliert war aber wir
müssen über diese Dinge reden ist
wichtig ja natürlich nicht dieser einen
Spruch und das wird sind wir mal ganz
ehrlich wir haben wirklich wir sind der
sozialste Sozialstaat den es weit und
breit gibt auf dieser Welt würde ich
jetzt mal einfach so in den Raum werfen
wir sind diejenigen die die Regeln
machen in diesem Land die Politiker
machen die Regeln in Griechenland und
wenn wir damit eine bestimmte Folge
Wirkung erzielen bei allen Menschen auf
dieser Welt dann brauchen wir uns
darüber nicht wundern also wenn wir was
geändert haben wollen dann müssen wir
die deutschen Gesetze ändern und dann
wird sich
Situationen wenn jemand aus einem
sicheren Drittstaat kommt dann brauchen
wir den nicht aufzunehmen
keine mehr dran dass das wirklich
funktionieren wird weil wir seit 2015
nicht rangekommen sind bedeutet aber das
dass diese Diskussion und dieser
Eindruck dass wir uns dem Problem nicht
stellen dass das dazu führen wird dass
wir bald selber hier in Deutschland eine
Frau Meloni wählen werden also wir haben
ja die Situation erstens dass wir sehen
die Menschen die aus der Ukraine fliehen
die fliehen nicht zu großen Teilen nach
Deutschland sondern die verteilen sich
eigentlich ganz gut nach Frankfurt
da könnte man auch mal dran arbeiten
auch einmal dran arbeiten
die Situation ist aber nicht dass die
Leute wegen der Sozialleistung aus der
Ukraine jetzt nach Deutschland findet
dafür einfach keine stat deutsche
Evidenz dann hat man die Situation
ehrlich gesagt dass
das deutsche Recht eben nicht so einfach
ist dass man im Grundgesetz mal einen
Artikel liest dann macht man die Grenze
zu und sagt du darfst hier nicht
reinkommen sondern man muss erstmal
schauen im dublin-system welcher Staat
ist eigentlich zuständig dafür ist die
Person dann also welche Gründe hat sie
dafür dass sie an der Grenze ist die
muss also ein erstmal rechtsstaatliches
Verfahren durchlaufen selbst bei einer
Einreiseverweigerung nach dem Schengener
grenzkodex braucht sie erstmal Papier
man kann nicht einfach sagen die Grenzen
sind jetzt zu bis bald tschüss da finde
ich da machen wir uns das so einfach
weil es hat bestimmte Gründe und das ist
alles komplett begrenzen müssen mit den
deutschen jetzt sagen wir begrenzen
diese Zahlen sowie was auf dem Höhepunkt
der flüchtlingskrise mit der Obergrenze
gemacht haben also es gab ja nie eine
Obergrenze aber wir haben ja durch auch
die hundertprozentration das heißt 2017
die Obergrenze wir haben keine
erreguläre Migration oder nicht ganz
kurzes Schlusswort wir kommen ans Ende
dieser Sendung Grenzen oder nicht wir
müssen das gut organisieren
also nicht begrenzen die Grünen wollen
nicht begrenzen denn man kann das
Asylrecht nicht begrenzen nein aber wir
reden doch
illegalen kann man nicht begrenzen das
vertiefen wir weiter wir werden weiter
in diesem Thema dran bleiben gerne auch
mit diesen Gästen mit Ihnen Herr
Marquardt und Ihnen Frau Schimke ich
danke für den angeregte Diskussion hier
in dieser Runde erhält er vielen Dank
alles Gute für ihre Zukunft Herr
Markwort Herr Marquardt Frosch im Grund
erfahren heute danke Ihnen herzlich bis
nächsten Montag dann zurück
[Musik]